we continue our coverage of Hurricane
durian as it slowly makes its way up the
southeast coast hitting much of Florida
with strong winds and heavy rain durian
is still a strong category 2 hurricane
but much much weaker than it was just a
few days ago the bad news is the storm
has actually widened meaning it could
reach a much larger area along the US
coast this morning we're seeing new
images of the incredible devastation
durian left behind in the Bahamas where
the official death toll has risen to at
least seven it must go up after that and
lead national correspondent David Beck
know is in the capital of Nassau where
relief efforts are now underway beg no
David please describe this scene there
where you're at right now
somebody Elena we are inside the private
Airport hangar here at the NASA air from
Airport listen this is the response to
the humanitarian crisis if you take a
look around the room there's everything
from security guards to Bahamian
National Guard's men and women to a
family from Arkansas Roger if you pan to
the left right there and show the family
we were talking to a moment ago they are
from Arkansas they have their own
organization of search and rescue they
flew their own plane in here so that
they could be a part of it that's what
we're talking about here folks just
showing up at the airport asking for
permission to go out and help to the
pictures now that we have that show just
the devastation right that has happened
around the Abaco Islands and Grand
Bahama it is catastrophic since the
storm has left here choppers are now
able to fly more of them and they've
captured some jaw-dropping images like
these showing communities and rubble and
ruin in Freeport on Grand Bahama Island
there is a terminal at the Grand Bahama
International Airport that is a mangled
mess of metal ripped open and gutted the
United States Coast Guard is so crucial
here right now they have deployed
resources and continue to aid the people
affected there's an mh-60 Jayhawk
helicopter several crews that are based
out of Andros Island that's just to the
southwest of where we are there are also
more than a dozen shallow water rescue
boats on standby now the Coast Guard
says it's rescued at least 47 people
here you can see responders aiding
medics and air lifting people out of the
marsh Harbor
on Abaco island that is where at least
60% of the homes are destroyed now along
the way crews captured images of the
devastation you can see boats tossed
around like toys stacked on top of each
other some communities are completely
underwater the United Nations estimates
60,000 people in the Bahamas have had
their homes flooded and are in need of
food and water 60,000 people and Anthony
think about this the Red Cross estimates
nearly 99% of people living in Grand
Bahama and Abaco Islands are in need of
some kind of assistance food water
something right now everybody feeling
the impact David thank you